Ukraine's president has urged people to
save electricity in the face of Russian
attacks on power facilities ukrainians
are experiencing rolling blackouts after
wave of strikes in the last two weeks a
lot mizalenski says cruise missiles and
iranian-made drones were used he says
attacking civilian facilities ahead of
winter amounts to terrorism
let's go straight to Harry Fawcett who's
live for us in Kiev Harry so what is the
latest in the situation then particular
when it comes to Ukraine's energy grid
well the ukrainians are saying there
were more strikes overnight they're not
specifying exactly what the targets were
but they are saying that they themselves
shot down some 16 of the Iranian uh
drones the lodging Munitions that have
been used uh by the Russian side in
recent days uh 14 of them uh in the
southern area around nikolaev and
another two in Northern and Eastern
Ukraine now these are fired in swarms so
the assumption is I I suppose that some
of them will have got through but as I
say no details as to exactly what was
hit but they are saying that there has
been a real shift in strategy towards
civilian infrastructure particularly in
terms of energy the strikes on Saturday
they said were as uh widespread as those
uh some 10 days earlier uh on on that
Monday when more than a hundred missiles
were fired uh most of them were a large
number of them targeting energy
infrastructure at one point they said
1.5 million ukrainians were without
power as results and so as you say the
president is talking about the need to
conserve energy on a personal basis on a
business basis we've also heard that the
city-wide central heating system which
is a hangover from the Communist period
uh that that has been turned on some
early in the winter about three days ago
to try to assist people who might
otherwise be using electricity to heat
their homes and as well as that there
are plans for mobile Heating units in
case that system gets targeted mobile
units on trucks that can plug into a
school or an office building or an
apartment building so that those bits of
infrastructure can be kept going even if
that city-wide system is being hit so
major preparations underway for what
could be a very difficult winter indeed
and the focus of the fighting in recent
days and weeks has been around the
Curson region what is the latest on that
front
yes uh there is something of a news
blackout being imposed by the ukrainians
in that area we can't get in there's not
very much being said from the Ukrainian
side but what we are hearing from the
Russians of course is that there is now
an immediate call for civilian uh
evacuation from her son we've seen those
images of people being taken across the
danipa river on ferries there are all
sorts of reports of Russian military uh
personnel and Hardware being taken out
as well in preparation for what is now
expected to be a Ukrainian Advance on
her son but both sides also accusing
each other of preparations to blow up a
very significant Dam at the kakovka Nova
hydroelectric power station which holds
back a vast amount of water in a
reservoir on the river Upstream from her
son so the the analysis coming from a
lot of of Western reports at least and
from the ukrainians is that there could
be some attempt by the Russians to mine
that it and blow it up to cover their
Retreat from her son which could be
extremely devastating the Russians
accusing the the ukrainians of planning
to launch strikes on that Dam as well
and then further north as well there are
reports from the ministry of Defense it
is it is noting a uh a plan put in place
it says by the head of the Wagner
private military group the Russian
private military group saying that there
are major defensive lines being put in
in place in the luhansk OR blast in uh
in what Russia has now said is annex
territory well behind the current front
lines so preparations potentially there
for a reinforcement behind any further
Ukrainian Advance into that territory
too
thank you for that update Harry Fawcett
there for us and Keith